Some say I’m the best in the world…
I agree with them.
I’m Lionel Messi.
I let my football speak for itself…
I should have played for the Spanish team.
Say your name!
Kevin.
People said I couldn’t carry Egypt...
They were right.
People say I lack focus
I say
focus on THIS
Rules are meant to be broken
so is Mo Salah
I’m not here to make friends
I’m here to make history
I’m not here to make friends either
but if I did make a friend
that’d be nice because I’m a bit lonely at Real
At first I thought it was a language barrier thing
but now I speak some Spanish
and still–
Man U?
More like Man Me
I don’t dress to impress
I dress to gegenpress
Can you tell us some more about yourself Kevin?
De Bruyne
Remember that amazing goal I scored to win the Puskas?
Neither do I
I'm Paul and I know how to make headlines
Yo la eh metido mas en Manchester que Noel Gallagher
I'm so good
I'm in the MLS, and they still put me in this intro
Everybody knows I’m at the same level as Messi and Ronaldo…
...why is everybody laughing?
Football is in my veins
Also growth hormones
Forget John Terry
I’m the real “Mr. Steal Your Girl”
[unintelligible]
Could we do that one more time, Harry?
I didn’t quite catch that
[unintelligible]
Alright, can we just get an actor in here?
Board up your windows
it’s Harry Kane season
Bayern is not sleeping
we’re just giving other teams in Bundesliga a head start
I dress in all black
because every game is a funeral for the other team
Right now this show is good
people are happy
But wait until Season 3
things will go very bad
I’m Fellaini
and in this show, I will NEVER cut my hair
Sorry—sorry I’m late
Uh, hello! I’m—
I am very happy for Luka that he won the Ballon d’Or
But mainly that Ronaldo didn’t win! Hahah!
I’m Phil Jones and nobody wants to face me
AND NOBODY WANTS ME FACE!
Robben, can you check your feet?
Make sure you’re on your mark
Oh, sure, yeah
Wait, I have two of these?!
I kick shins and knees like they’re balls.
I also kick balls like they’re balls.
I am so pumped to join Chelsea,
because I was in danger
of actually winning things at Dortmund,
and that would go against everything
the U.S. men's national team believes in.
Every time we get a bad result,
I take a hard look in the mirror...
and I blame the officials, the wind,
the cut of the grass, the smells of the stadium, the
I’m back, and winning
is in my jeans.
If you need a cross into the box,
pray you have an Angel on your wing.
Money can't buy you silverware...
is what the chairman keeps telling me.
Don't hate me because I'm beautiful.
Hate me because I had a great World Cup
five years ago
and not much else.
I'm not the new Ronaldo.
I'm the first Vinicius.
Oh, except for Vinicius Sr.
Despite recent results,
we already got the historic quadruple this season.
We were investigated by
UEFA, FIFA, the FA and the Premier League!
I followed in the footsteps of the greats...
by leaving Southampton!
You think Icardi's a dog?
I shagged me brother's missus.
-Alright, and that's all we need.
Thank you for coming in, Mr. Giggs.
I'm one of the best players in the world...
according to my paycheck.
People say I would be good in the Premier League,
but first I need to be good in Serie A.
Thanks, Kepa, but, ugh, we actually need a Champions League goalkeeper.
So, ugh, if you could just, ugh, go ahead and get off the set.
It was just a cramp. I'm staying. You can't make me go!
Zizou's back! Isco be alright.
And for my next trick,
I will make myself reappear as a relevant player!
Now that the transfer window is over,
I could spend more time pursuing my hobbies.
Ya know, like playing football!
Hi, this is me, Christian Eriksen!
I love to play football for Tottenham Hotspur, I'm so happy!
Ah, no. Hello.
Watch out Champions League,
it's time for Atlanta to rock your world.
Uh, it's Atalanta.
Ah, s--t.
I am so sick of all the vanity and the egos in Paris.
That is why next season, I'm going to Miami.
If you come at Napoli, be prepared to get a pizza me...
Ever since I was a young boy, I dreamed of playing for Juv...
Piemonte Calcio
And just remember, don't overlook Olympiacos!
This Halloween, I dressed up as a real, Premier League man.
Hat-trick-or-treat!
Ever since coming to Barcelona, it’s been difficult to connect with Messi.
He's never online!
OK. Just hold on for one second. I want to send this.
It's going to be so funny.
What, what? Oh, no. Oh, no.
Delete, delete, delete, delete!